نتابع هذه الصور من القدس الغربيه قبل
قليل حيث فضت الشرطه الاسرائيليه احتجاجا
لمتظاهرين اغلقوا الطرق المؤديه للكنيست
للمطالبه باجراء
انتخابات
مبكره
تشفشف
تفش
عشف
عشش
اذا ننوه مشاهدينا الى ان هذه صور وردتنا
قبل قليل من القدس
الغربيه حيث فضت الشرطه الاسرائيليه
احتجاجا لمتظاهرين اغلقوا الطريق المؤدي
للكنيست للكنيست للمطالبه باجراء انتخابات
مبكره
بدم لمتابعه معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري وليد كنت سابدا معك
من تصريحات بتسل سموتريش لكن بمناسبه هذه
الصور التي وردت قبل قليل لفض الشرطه
الاسرائيليه
لاحتجاج محتجين حاولوا اغلاق الطريق
المؤدي الى الكنيست للمطالبه بانتخابات
مبكره هل نحن ازاء تعاظم الحاله
الاحتجاجيه في في اسرائيل على السياسه
الحكوميه فيما يتعلق بهذه
الحرب هذه من تداعيات المظاهرات التي كانت
يوم السبت مساء في حيفا
وقيسارية التي بدايتها ونواتها الصلبه هم
ذو الاسرائيليين المحتجزين والاسرى في
قطاع غزه وايضا التي شملت الدعوه الى
اقاله نتنياهو وحكومته وتوليف اليمينيه
المفرطه في في تطرفها هذه المجموعه التي
قامت صباح هذا اليوم باغلاق احدى الطرق
المؤديه الى الكنيست وقامت الشرطه بفضه
وقمعهم هي من بدايات هذا التفاعل المرشح
ان يتواصل وقد يصل يسجل ذروه مع اليوم
المئه من الحرب على غزه بعد ان اعلنت
نقابه العاملين الاسرائيليين الهستدروت
وهي اكبر النقابات التي
تؤطر العاملين والموظفين في اسرائيل عن
انها ستوقف العمل وتشل اسرائيل ل 100
دقيقه في اليوم المئه للحرب على غزه اي
بعد سته ايام لذلك بدات تظهر في اسرائيل
هذه المظاهر وهذه الاحتجاجات التي ترى ان
نتنياهو ووليفته اليمينيه المتطرفه انما
يوظفون هذه الحرب بهدف استدامه حكمهم
واستدامه حكومتهم وان نتنياهو معني
باستمرار الحرب الى اطول فتره ممكنه وذلك
للحقول دون ان تبدا لجنه تحقيق رسميه
عملها حول الفشل الذريع الذي منيت به
الاستخبارات والامن وايضا الجيش وكذلك
القياده السياسيه الاسرائيليه ونتنياهو
كما هو معروف كان قد رفض حتى الان وتنصل
من ان يعلن تحمله للمسؤوليه كما فعل كافه
القاده سواء العسكريين او حتى الوزراء مثل
وزير الدفاع وغيره لذلك هذه الاصوات
تتزايد ويتزايد معها المؤشر على حسب
استطلاعات الراي واخرها ما بثته ونقلته
القناه الرسميه الاسرائيليه القناه 11
المعروفه بكان الليله الماضيه عن استطلاع
يشير الى ان بيني جانس زعيم المعسكر
الدوله مازال يتقدم بفارق كبير وقد حقق
تقدما وانه فيما لو جرت الانتخابات الان
فانه سيحصل على 33 مقعدا في الكنيست مقابل
20 فقط لنتنياهو لكن الاهم في النتيجه كان
هو ان الائتلاف اليمين الحاكم حاليا
برئاسه نتنياهو والذي يضم بالاضافه للكود
ال العنصريين وغلات المتطرفين من حزب
الصهيونيه الدينيه وعظمه يهوديه سموتريتش
وبن جفير واحزاب المتدينين المتشددين هذه
هذا التوليفه لن تستطيع جمع اكثر من 46
نائبا بما معناها فيما اذا لو جرت
الانتخابات فانها ستسقط وهذا الاستطلاع
وامثاله سبب وجيه في نظر نتنياهو وتوليف
على الاستمرار في الحكم استمرار هذه الحرب
لانهم يدركون جيدا فيما لو ذهبوا الى
الانتخابات فانهم سيفشلون في تحقيق اغلبيه
تتيح لهم اقامه حكومه جديده هذا من ناحيه
من ناح ناحيه اخرى بعد 994 يوما من هذه
الحرب الضاريه على قطاع غزه كل التقديرات
في اسرائيل تشير الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
حتى الان واجهزه الامنيه المختلفه اخفقت
في ان تحقق انجازا استراتيجيا يقربها من
الاهداف التي اعلنتها سواء كان ذلك بما
تصفه اباده حماس او قضيه تفكيك قدراتها
العسكريه
والسلطوية فينا كما يسميهم الاسرائيليون
والذين يقدرون عددهم بنحو
136 او ايا منهم حيا والامر الثالث وهو ما
كان وعد به نتنياهو هو ان تكف قطاع غزه عن
ان يصبح يشكل خطرا على اسرائيل او على
جنوبها هذه الامور مجتمعه لم يحققوا منها
شيئا وكل ما تحقق حتى الان هو المزيد من
القتل والدمار والتدمير في قطاع غزه وهو
ما ب بات يقلق قطاعات
متزايده خاصه اولئك من ذوي الاسرى
والمحتجزين في غزه الذين يرون ان استمرار
هذه الحرب يعرض ابنائهم المحتجزين لمزيد
من الخطر والقتل لذلك بداوا يرفعون شعارات
تطالب بضروره وقف اطلاق النار فورا
والدخول في مفاوضات لابرام صفقه تبادل
شامله حتى لو اضطرت اسرائيل في اطارها
الافراج عن جميع الاسرى الفلسطينيين في
مقابل استعاده
كافه المحتجزين في قطاع غزه والتي تعقدت
بعد ان اغتالت اسرائيل القائد الفلسطيني
صالح العاروري نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي
لحركه حماس شكرا لك من رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري